well from gender to good paying jobs
the biden administration seems intent on
destroying it all
on joe biden's first day in office he
killed
thousands of american jobs
joe biden killed hundreds of wisconsin
jobs
we're talking about 10 000 jobs in the
80 90 000
an hour range that are gone
joining me now is andy black president
and ceo of the association
of oil pipelines andy i know the
canadians are up in arms they've already
laid all this pipe i don't know where
they what are they going to do with all
that pipe that they've already
laid down and all the technology that's
already in place
how much in terms of
job losses are we looking at here and
then we're going to get to how much
money is taken out of american pockets
before wednesday had ended on president
biden's first day
one thousand people who had been working
were told
they won't have jobs anymore another ten
thousand american
union jobs were expected they expected
good paying jobs that could support a
family provide health care
those won't happen now well andy
it was showing the video of what the
area around the pipeline looks like
uh and some of this is in canada and
other parts of the united states but
what happens with all of that
infrastructure
andy that's in place well it's a symbol
of a wasted opportunity
americans would benefit from that
pipeline bringing
western canadian crude oil down to
america where it's turned
into products that we use every day to
get us where we need to go
now it turns out that money was wrongly
spent
and by the way joe biden i should say is
bragging
that he's going to create all these
great union jobs
watch when i think of climate change
i think about jobs good paying union
jobs
union workers have been holding this
country together during this crisis
that the middle class built this country
and unions
built the middle class andy those were
all in the past month do you think union
members who voted
for biden feel like they've been just
hosed here
this is a president who said he wanted
to be the most pro-union president ever
yet on the first day 11 000 american
union workers knew they weren't going to
be able to build
build back better means build
well andy the cost to the average
american family i know these are hard
numbers to always quantify
but in terms of energy costs and our
desire to be energy independent
which obviously this gave us an
incredible
boost in an already strong energy sector
but what does this mean to the average
family is it is it like a blip or is
this significant dollars
americans don't want to have to pay more
for energy and they
when they go to the service station to
fill up with gasoline or diesel
they want to know that that fuel is
there
now we have a question about whether we
can expand pipeline capacity
as we need for the fuels that we use in
our daily lives
when we get this economy going again
people are going to be wanting to take
trips to go see family in the car take
flights on vacation or see their
relatives
we need to make sure that as our demand
for energy grows
we're able to have pipelines bring them
the fuels that they need
without enough pipeline capacity you
either have shortages
or you have higher prices or maybe we're
all looking forward to having rolling
blackouts like in california apparently
that's the gold standard andy just the
government gets to decide who has energy
and when maybe we can do odd and even
days
at the gas pump like we did in the late
70s under jimmy carter andy
great to see you tonight and we hope we
can somehow turn that around but people
have to know what they're getting into